que todos anteriores.
Creo que inconscientemente, los humanos, de alguna manera, también hacemos eso.
Nos damos un poco de tiempo para comenzar el juego,
para obtener una sensación del mercado, o lo que sea, cuando somos jóvenes.
Y luego empezamos a buscar seriamente posibles candidatos matrimoniales
cuando llegamos a mediados o finales de los 20 años.
Creo que esto es una prueba concluyente, por si hiciera falta,
de que el cerebro de todo el mundo está programado
para actuar un poco matemáticamente
Este fue el consejo práctico número 2.
Ahora, el consejo práctico número 3: Cómo evitar el divorcio.
Imaginemos ahora que eligieron la pareja perfecta
y que se proyectan con ella para una relación de por vida.
Me gusta pensar que lo ideal es que todos traten de evitar el divorcio,
aparte de, no sé, quizás, la esposa de Piers Morgan.
Pero es un hecho triste de la vida moderna
que 1 de cada 2 matrimonios en EE.UU., termina en divorcio,
y en los otros países, la cosa es del mismo orden.
Probablemente podría perdonarse
si se piensa que las disputas que preceden a una ruptura matrimonial
no sean un buen punto para investigación matemática.
Por una parete, es muy difícil saber
qué se debe medir o qué se debe cuantificar.
Pero esto no impidió que un psicólogo, John Gottman, hiciera exactamente eso.
Gottman observó cientos de parejas conversando
y grabó todo lo que se puedan imaginar.
Grabó lo que se decía en las conversaciones,
grabó su conductividad de la piel,
grabó sus expresiones faciales,
su ritmo cardíaco, la presión arterial,
básicamente todo, aparte de si la mujer era en realidad la que siempre tenía razón,
que, por cierto, en realidad así era.
Pero lo que encontraron Gottman y su equipo
fue que uno de los indicadores más importantes
para saber si una pareja iba a divorciarse o no,
era lo positivo o negativo que era cada uno en la conversación.
Ahora, las parejas de bajo riesgo
mostraban muchos más puntos positivos que negativos en la escala de Gottman.
Mientras que las malas relaciones,
las que probablemente se divorciarían,
se hallaban en una espiral de negatividad.
Solo usando estas ideas sencillas
Gottman y su grupo pudieron predecir
si una pareja concreta se iba a divorciar
con una precisión del 90 %.
Pero no fue hasta asociarse con un matemático, James Murray,
que empezaron a entender realmente
qué causan las espirales de negatividad y cómo se producen.
Y los resultados que encontraron
son increíble e impresionantemente simples e interesantes.
Las ecuaciones predicen cómo la esposa o el marido responderá
en su siguiente turno de la conversación;
qué tan positivos o negativos serán.
Estas ecuaciones, dependen
del estado de ánimo de la persona cuando está sola,
su estado de ánimo cuando está con su pareja,
pero lo más importante, dependen
de lo mucho que el esposo y la esposa se influyen mutuamente.
En este punto, creo que es importante destacar,
que precisamente estas ecuaciones han demostrado también
que pueden perfectamente describir
lo que sucede entre dos países en una carrera armamentista.
(Risas)
Es que, una pareja que discute en la espiral de negatividad
y se tambalea al borde del divorcio,
en realidad, equivale matemáticamente al comienzo de una guerra nuclear.
(Risas)
Pero lo que es realmente importante en esta ecuación
es cómo se influyen las personas entre sí,
y, en particular, cómo influye el llamado umbral de negatividad.
Puede pensarse en el umbral de negatividad,
como lo molesto que puede estar el marido
antes de que la mujer empiece a enfadarse verdaderamente, y viceversa.
Siempre pensé que los buenos matrimonios se basaban en el compromiso y la comprensión
en permitirse ambos tener sus espacios para ser ellos mismos.
Había pensado que quizás las relaciones más exitosas
eran aquellas en las que había un umbral muy alto de negatividad.
Cuando las parejas dejan pasar ciertas cosas
y solo discuten asuntos realmente problemáticos.
Pero, en realidad, las matemáticas y los resultados posteriores del equipo
han demostrado, que lo contrario es lo correcto.
Las mejores parejas, las más exitosas,
son las que tienen un umbral muy bajo de negatividad.
Son parejas que no pasan por alto las cosas, que no las ignoran
y se permiten espacios para quejarse.
Son parejas que continuamente están tratando de arreglar la relación,
que tienen una visión del matrimonio mucho más positiva.
Las parejas que no pasan por alto las cosas
que no dejan que cosas triviales terminen siendo grandes problemas.
Ahora, por supuesto, se necesita algo más que un bajo umbral de negatividad
y no aceptar nada distinto de una relación exitosa.
Creo que es bastante interesante
saber que hay de verdad evidencia matemática
para poder afirmar que nunca debemos dejar que la ira nos ciegue.
Así que estos son mis tres consejos
de cómo las matemáticas pueden ayudarles con el amor y las relaciones.
Pero espero, aparte de los consejos útiles,
haberles dado también alguna idea del poder de las matemáticas.
Porque para mí, las ecuaciones y los símbolos no son solo una cosa,
son una voz que habla acerca de la increíble riqueza de la naturaleza
y la simplicidad sorprendente de los patrones
que giran, se tuercen, se deforman y se desarrollan a nuestro alrededor,
desde cómo funciona el mundo hasta la manera de comportamos.
Así que espero que tal vez, solo para algunos de Uds.
algo de comprensión de las matemáticas del amor
pueda persuadirles de tener un poco más de amor por las matemáticas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)